the one goodbye that i know jared and i
both
had to deal with was the goodbye to
uh the winchester brothers and that was
felt
that was that was really heavy and
you'll see it reflected in the episode
the whole mission is saving the world
this is where it ends we didn't have it
next season
um and so we knew we were coming back
for those episodes that we had been
preparing for
uh about a month or two um so it was
nice to know that
there was a carrot at the end of the
stick um and then we get back to go
uh visit sam and dean winchester again
my entire life
you've kept me
the mindset of kind of prepping to say
goodbye
as you were up there shooting the
regular production season then covet
hits you go home
now you go back for those six weeks
uninterrupted have you guys had to kind
of
re-evaluate saying goodbye are you
finding did you have to like re-get into
this
mind-state of wow it's over again i
don't know
what this says about me but i was
dreading the goodbye
in march not because i didn't want to
say goodbye but just
i don't i'm not good with goodbyes you
know i just don't like saying goodbye
and yeah i hope you have a great life
i i don't like that um and so the fact
that it got put off
i was almost a little relieved knowing
that it would have to come at some point
when we came back
it was now it was like you couldn't hug
and you couldn't touch each other and
you couldn't be within six feet and
there were masks and so you couldn't see
smiles and it was almost like this
weird diet version of saying goodbye
that for me i was like good i didn't
want to say goodbye anyway
i often say you know when the people
that do
like to sit in that goodbye be like no
it's okay to say goodbye and it's it's
okay
i i felt like it was um i was saying
we'll see you later i'll see you when
this pandemic's over i'll see you when
there's not a mask on your face we'll
see when i'm able to hug you
and i'll see you when i'm able to to
properly
embrace you and say thank you for so
many years
so i won't say goodbye right now i'll
just say see you when
when when i can't see you yeah i think
uh similar for me um and i feel like
try and again find a silver lining this
horrible pandemic we've
dealt with um it sort of
taught me um a bit brutally like hey
things aren't going to work out exactly
the way they're supposed to things
aren't going to
be exactly the way you thought or you'd
like or you'd wish
make the most of it and so i think i
think a lot of
my mindset for the last six weeks has
been just make the most of it you know
it's obviously less than ideal like
jensen touched on with people wearing
masks and
we were joking you know we when we would
walk upset we had
we had one way we could walk onto set
and one way to walk off
like covet regulations and so when we'd
walk off set
like i think he and i both felt like the
the stereotypical
sort of like ass factor like all the
crew would start like the sea would part
like hey like these people we hug we're
like oh yeah they're not running from us
because they don't want to see us or
because we've told
the producer like don't don't let them
look in our eyes because like these are
our friends they just have to they have
to answer to their bosses they don't
want them within 10 feet of us
um so you're yelling from your little
tape mark out on your way to your
trailer like hey
how's it going how's quarantine good to
see ya you got a new tattoo blah blah
so that was difficult but we made the
most of it and we got to kind of spend
like jensen said like we didn't really
say goodbye to anybody we said see you
later
and we've both been around long enough
that to know
that whether or not we do make it to
vancouver again or somebody makes to
austin
it really was goodbye to a lot of people
you know there are certainly people
we'll see again
um but we've all been around different
sets long enough where
uh you're like oh my god i've loved you
guys intimately for
a month on a little movie or two months
on a bigger movie or whatever the case
is it's like i can't wait to see you
again and
here you are 20 years later you haven't
seen him again um so i understand that
it was goodbye to a lot of people
um but i understand that i will see a
lot of the other ones again and now
we're all getting used to zoom and
facetime and we can easily at least see
each other's faces
albeit from afar uh so just trying to
keep our heads up about it
i will say matt uh i'll add to that real
quick
that the one the one goodbye that i know
jared and i
both had to deal with
was the goodbye to uh the winchester
brothers
that was felt that was that was really
heavy
and you'll see it reflected
in the episode uh
the the emotion of it anyway because
there's
there's certainly parts of of the final
episode
where uh the
the character and the human
being playing that character uh their
emotions are very intertwined
jensen ackles here and jared padalecki
on our last
and final day shooting supernatural our
last shot
as a matter of fact that's right we just
want to thank you for uh
for being with us for 15 years now and
uh it's been a great pleasure
and an honor to have you supporting us
all these years with
covid's situation and all the safety
protocols and things that you guys are
having to deal with what was that last
moment like
with with whatever goodbye you could say
to the crew yeah
that was a funny day we were up in the
gbrd
uh up in vancouver and there's no cell
phone service there
and so it wasn't it wasn't like a
classic day where you're
facetiming your wife and talking to the
kids and helping them
get down to bed or telling them to eat
their dinner or checking in with friends
and family and all that
it was it was like okay well now i'm
halfway to set
and i'm about to have 20 minutes into a
place that has no cell phone service and
so it kind of forced you to be present
even though so much of you wants to
distract yourself and be like
uh this isn't happening i'm gonna call
my kids hey guys you're like uh i see my
kids they're smiling they're excited
it was really forcing us to be there and
the final you know
um that's a wrap it didn't happen
immediately it wasn't like the scene was
over and it was okay cut
you know check the gate that's a wrap uh
bob who directed finale
um walked over to us and a lot of the
other crew
uh walked up and he kind of looked
around and you know he kind of took his
moment and we all kind of took a moment
he's like okay
well um that's a wrap you know it was
pretty
like i get a little warm in my throat
even talking about it
yeah i had i had cried a lot of tears in
the literally
seven months since i had read the
scripts the last two scripts because we
got them in either late january or
february
so i had my chance to cry my tears i'm
glad i did because
that last day though it was bittersweet
it was more sweet than bitter
you know because i was like okay i got i
got the sadness out to some degree i'm
sure it'll come again
but selfishly i was like man i can look
around and smile and there were a lot of
tears all over
but echoes and i were kind of looking at
each other like man we just it's like
finishing the seattle marathon or
whatever it's like okay we did it
dude we did it you know we put in the
work it wasn't like hey we're famous or
hey we have
you know this many followers it was like
hey i've been with you for 15 years 15
and a half years
i've seen you sweat i've seen you bleed
i've seen you hurt i've seen
you going through stuff personally and
put it aside
for this show for your character and i
know i've done the same
and it was just it was it was
bittersweet but it was sweet man it was
happy
it felt like i could do this again
for 15 seasons okay let's let's call
peter rod to mark pedowitz and see if
they uh
if they'll rip us for 15 more there was
certainly a satisfaction
i think that that occurred
of you know we we did it we did it
you know it was it was definitely a an
emotional high-five moment
congratulations in completing
the unthinkable task you know to to
bring a show to birth the show
to carry out a show at a high level for
a long time
and to complete a show at a high level
for a long time while maintaining
who you guys are tease me with something
in the final episodes for the fans uh
are they going to see a cliffhanger are
they going to see
uh period to the end of things give me a
little something for the fans to grab
onto
to tease the finale uh it is
supernatural so as you know
it's always a cliffhanger uh no matter
how it ends
uh that that cliff is hanging beyond
that
episode 19 is more like the season
finale
of season 15. episode 20 is like the
series finale
and so like any good series finale in my
opinion uh it pays homage
to the beginnings and so jensen and i
worked in
a few uh so the writers did on their own
but he and i also worked in a few little
homages to those out there
who uh who have been around since the
get and uh
who are familiar with the canon and lore
and history of supernatural
so there are a few little uh easter eggs
in there oh i'm i'm excited i'm excited
because especially the one uh
the one at the end those that know will
pick up on it oh yeah
no we'll just think it's normal but and
that was all jared he
he said he said hey i got an idea and i
was like oh
of course we're doing that yeah um
so there was yeah it's you know the
final episode
uh there there's some easter eggs that
are laid in there for
um for the hardcore fans for sure uh
and and it's also um i'll say this
it's it's really nice to see the
brothers doing what they
are so good at our last chance our one
shot
you're sheltering a great burden we have
a choice for the long
long time fans keep an eye out uh there
are a lot of homages
we end the way we began to some degree
yeah
families have been part of this schedule
this structure
this existence for jared and jensen
you're being tired you hopping on planes
you
hopping off planes us going to these
conventions that all doesn't exist
anymore how are the families uh dealing
with this the kids the wives
um when are you gonna let your kids
watch the show have they seen any scenes
and do they have any idea how big it is
you know if it's not
paw patrol then my kids aren't
interested anyways uh they know i work
with uncle jensen they know we play
pretend
um we both jen's and i both have had
instances where we pick up a facetime
from
our wives and it's one of the kids and
we happen to have blood or something and
they're like
why do you hurt why are you bleeding
it's not real it's
with uncle jensen look uncle jensen
touch it um
so i think you know i think jen is
excited to have her
uh her less than stellar assistant back
in austin to take out the garbage and
this was recently yeah so i think
i i know a dad who's three and a half
now she keeps going dad are you coming
back at austin texas
today like not today baby girl okay
tomorrow i see you at austin tomorrow
i'm like
but it was also the build-up to our
final day
of supernatural was so sad that you know
hopping on facetime with jen and the
kids and going like this is what i'm
getting back to
what was a nice way to you know keep the
tears at bay
when all i want to do is cry and say
goodbye to sam winchester and
supernatural
um so they're excited you know i think
jen's excited to have me
help run around and play basketball with
kids and baseball and soccer whatever
chase lizards
uh pick chicken eggs and all that um i
can't wait
i'll be home in a couple of days um i
gotta just drive across country
take my time say goodbye i have to talk
about the post-supernatural moment for
you both because
as much as i'm heartbroken to not be
your dad in the past and see you guys as
sam dean
i am thrilled for your futures i think
these moves are incredible
jared i'm talking about walker
and the new news that are lovely uh
genevieve padalecki
uh is is joining you as your on-screen
wife and and
jensen you playing kind of this original
captain america-like superhero on the
boys talk to me about both of these
projects
okay i'll start um yeah it just got
announced that jen is going to be
playing my uh
my dead wife on uh on walker which is
cool so we'll be in austin together
and uh getting you to work together
again how we met
missed opportunity missed opportunity
yeah i get to pretend so jens and i have
already gotten to pretend to kill my
wife
and now i get to deal with her as as
dead uh
no but she gets to be in the show which
is amazing um she's such a big part of
the show anyways whether she was on
screen with me or or not um
that'll be fun to work there again and
to work in austin i haven't worked in
austin
since 2008 but to sleep in bed um
at home and to be a part of my kids
zoom classes i guess before i go to work
or whenever i get home or whatever the
schedule's gonna be like
when the commute doesn't involve an
aircraft it's always nice
yes exactly as you well know too man um
yeah i'm thrilled i'm thrilled to tell
the story uh we're really proud of the
stories we have and the
the themes we're kind of dealing with um
and so you know i didn't want to and i
said this before publicly like i didn't
want to
work after supernatural i was like i'm
done man like
i'll get a phone call from a buddy and
go do a show hopefully that's i mean
that seems kind of
arrogant like all all except phone calls
but i mean like i didn't want to go seek
work
and then this storyline came up and the
cast characters
kind of started getting built and i was
like oh man i'm
i'm ready to jump back in the pool if
they'll have me you know um
so to be a part of developing it and
producing it and creating it
has been really special and new ground
um
i'm thrilled uh and my my love for my
new project
i want to stress this does not in any
way detract from
my my love and gratitude for
the project we all just finished
together well
jonathan what do you got buddy i've been
a fan of the show uh
since i saw the first episode so uh when
i was
talking to kripke over the the court
over the the
quarantine break uh i just basically
mentioned i'm like hey
somebody's gonna be unemployed pretty
soon what's happening over there in uh
in your world and that uh
and that kind of started the
conversation and and he called me the
next day he's like look there's
there is a role coming up in in season
three that
um that he's like i could i could see
you
throwing your hat in the ring for and i
was like okay
and i wanna i'll i will stress this that
this wasn't a
crippy calling me and like hey now that
you're available i got something for you
come on over and that was it
they had already they were already out
so like some some
uh heavy hitters and guys that i was
like i can't compete with that like what
are you
and so i thought i had to fight for it i
had to fight for it uh and i'm glad i
did because
uh like i said i'm a fan of the show i
think they're doing really cool stuff
over there
it's uh you know it's it's a it's kind
of next level stuff
uh i talked to phil segresia who who
obviously was with us
on supernatural for so so many years
he's over there doing
um doing really great stuff he's
directing he's producing he's uh
post-bruising
and so he was telling me he's like get
strapped in pal because it's
this this is a this is a different kind
of beast uh so i'm excited about that
i'm excited to see
uh you know just a different uh
a different house go visit somebody's
somebody else's house for for a change
um i will of course miss the one that we
built for 15 years but
uh i think this is uh this will be a fun
move
and an exciting move and like i said
there's there's still familiar faces
over there so it won't
it won't be i won't be completely uh
fish out of water but
um i'm excited to put on a superhero
outfit too that's
that's kick ass i actually have to go
actually have to be in la for the next
couple of months because
it takes that long to build it so it's
like
every two weeks you got to go in for a
fitting and they build and build and
build and these things are like
works of art um so i'm excited for that
it's uh
yeah it'll be cool finally something
that my you know three-year-old son
can be really proud of because you know
a flannel shirt
and and some some boots are not uh are
not the coolest thing to a
three-year-old but
a guy with a mask and a shield and a 12
pack of superhero costume abs or
whatever you're gonna look like
those are those are real jared those are
[Music]
real